foreign
[Music]
you guys must be new to town right new
to town but not new to the country we
just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you wouldn't mind if your
daughter played with our daughter Audrey
say hi
[Music]
slides off limits to Ching chongs
cute
do you want to be best friends look at
me look at me look at me now guess who's
going back to the motherland it's a big
deal going to your birth country I used
to talk about it all the time when we're
little remember Grand Adventure to find
your birth mother so proud of you
y'all calling me crazy my translator in
Beijing Audrey I got you ready
[Laughter]
lives there now your famous college
roommate are you ready to lose to a
celebrity
come from
you know I think I get it I called the
adoption agency and she lives in hygiene
okay will you guys come with me [__] yes
[__] I love a grand Adventure
oh hi so nice to see an American what do
you do for work it's the cops are doing
a back check
you're drug dealers now
we can't get caught with drugs in China
we'll get jailed for life
never come to China people are always
thinking that I have this perfect life I
don't belong anywhere if you do not know
where you come from how do you know who
you are
still find her our passports are in my
suitcase that got stolen you know we can
bypass the airport security K-pop Stars
everyone remember their names sassy Lisa
Lisa too I don't
I don't know
girls show them
um
you're a fan of cardi B right yeah but
is she here
there's some [__] in this house
did you get the coke bags out yeah but
only seven and I think I put in eight
just push pull I mean
my [__]
foreign
Fields welcome
I am
you will make a very good assistant no
he's evil we will protect you you have
the word of the most trusted institution
on Earth the Catholic Church
[Music]
your sole purpose in life is to serve me
now let's see
I just want a normal life again
God bless you Mr Renfield oh God bless
you nuns your hero Robert Montague
wrenches
let me explain I work for Dracula Count
Dracula
it's the real Dracula some call me the
dark one
others the Lord of death so you bring
and people to eat well I do other stuff
like what washes cake no the Cape is dry
clean only strictly yeah I will wear
this it's fly yeah
I don't think he's such a bad guy but
you're never really gonna be free until
you face him I will no longer tolerate
abuse I deserve happiness
you deserve only suffering I will
unleash and all that does everyone you
care about will suffer because you
betrayed me we have to stop him Before
Sunset
[Music]
I deserve happiness and I take full
charge
[Music]
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is gonna be my way worse my least
favorite part of the job
foreign
[Applause]
that wasn't nice nothing but bad news
for the Iowa stallions what an idiot
Mr Markovich I will offer you community
service coaching adults with
intellectual disabilities
no boo-boo words
okay fellas fellas we're going to do a
simple ball handling exercise my
girlfriend loves this
it's impossible to coach these guys
you don't have to turn them into
them and just need to feel like a team
we're gonna need some help you're
getting a player off the injured list
welcome to the team cousin Tina what's
with the boogie board you do you I do me
okay where do you got this guy he just
showed up one day
Alex going to do copper karaoke with us
okay now you gotta keep me down
hey we got next Don't make me say it
make you say why
that's a boo-boo word we got next coach
just doesn't feel right
[Music]
I should be coaching in the NBA well you
never know where things could lead
no doubt
you can get this team to this Special
Olympics finals you might be ready to be
back in the NBA we've been following
your incredible story coach Marcus is
just one win away from qualifying for
the regional tournament I don't know if
you're brave or crazy
I know this is your shot at being
champions
[Music]
girlfriend problems that was fun you
were passable I don't have a girlfriend
makes sense oh what am I that bad
looking
you know McConaughey
stop Gary court order for asset seizures
so they're taking my car you and radio
silent on me is that what this is about
my feelings for you were so intense that
I got scared is that true no that's my
cousin Gary I swear to God he's my
cousin he's my second cousin there's
something seriously wrong with you I'm
an Uber driver and I don't have a car
I'm gonna lose my house you think I
chose him
look at this need a car date our son
this summer and bring him out of his job
before College in exchange will give you
a Buick Regal date is in quotes
husband the code breaker
he's just been so worried about our son
he's going to Princeton in the fall no
I've heard of it you know we tried
everything to bring him out of his shell
he doesn't come out of his room he
doesn't talk to girls and drinks so when
you say date him do you mean date him or
date him yes date him date him hard I'll
date his brains out he volunteers at the
animal shelter
hi mind if I touch your wiener what your
dog
how about I give you a ride home
um this isn't the way to my house the
shortcut you're my hostage what you got
down there something for me
why you tried kidnapping me you're 19.
grow up
this kid is Undateable have a drink
together he'll have a Long Island Iced
Tea
this is the worst iced tea I've ever had
one thing about me dance party I don't
know what to do I just know my mom would
have wanted me to save the house I'm
just nervous loosen them up you can go
skinny dipping what about sharks been
here jellyfish not the season it's
really the lack of life partner right
now okay
he's actually really sweet
it's part about getting older is not
having to care what people think I'm an
adult now I can make my own decisions
that's good you want to save her save
her
come on you're getting out of here you
don't belong here don't touch me get
away from her
[Music]
Maddie you can't outrun the cops I can't
lose my license
all right
since the beginning of time
since the first little girl ever existed
there have been dolls
but the dolls were always and forever
baby dolls
until
[Music]
foreign
Kingdom
[Music]
[Applause]
Bowser is coming I'm not afraid I'll do
anything for my brother we're going to
save him
yes foreign
oh
[Music]
my parents are inviting us to the Summer
Place for the big Fourth of July weekend
I can't leave my father this is the
first summer since we have to say
goodbye to your dear Mother and you're
going to leave me to burn the spot
because alone
bring it no I don't think so
did you hear this ladies he's worried
his immigrified is going to make it look
like some kind of Goomba unless if we're
gonna do this Dad you gotta dial it down
what is this
wow this this is amazing
[Music]
yeah of an affection man unlike you when
you met me at the delivery room you
chose to shake my hands what else was I
supposed to do we just met
Sebastian I don't know how you're gonna
fit in
don't these people have jobs they got
their money in the stock market not
mayonnaise jars buried in their backyard
I just hope nothing gets stolen this
weekend because these people love to
blame the immigrants
the grant to work this is Doug he's
learning to be a Healer hello what are
you doing just serenading our pet
peacock
I love you these people are strange they
have birds for a place he's like
he's like peacocks are just a bunch of
goddamn show-offs if you ask me
I was nervous to bring you here but I
didn't know you were gonna spend the
whole time embarrassing me how could you
say that to your father Here We Go Again
everything I'm doing for you that I've
ever done for you is for your own good
hey Dad check it out I can die I'm
trying to make sure that you don't make
an ass out of yourself by trying to be
somebody you're not
oh my god oh [__] Sebastian your suit
it's Versace do you like it no you [__]
it's not up
I would love to make a full Italian
dinner for everybody we don't keep a lot
of food here Amanda scalco always finds
a way to feed his family
my father has an old Italian saying
family isn't one important thing it's
everything I can't believe we put this
all together from what we have in the
kitchen it's not a joke and poultry
absolutely
[Music]
oh no
you slide up their pet pee packed and
you thought I was crazy for worrying
that you were gonna make us look like
some bad Italian stairs that's right to
help me get rid of the evidence why does
it seem like you've done this before
what kind of story were you thinking
about how something to prison oh all
right
and uh what about a prison interests you
jail
for sure
happy anniversary we're so lucky yeah
so Elliot tells me you're a writer and
your last one it should have done better
there's lots of new voices refugees
cancer murder abuse I'm an old voice
you're the best voice maybe if Dad
hadn't just been verbally abusive it
would have been a bestseller don't say
that
Memoir is great your new book is great
how are you feeling uh a little off my
game the only reason she makes me a
salad is because she wants me to lose
weight which is passive aggressive I
want you to be healthy it doesn't matter
can you shut up and keep talking come on
you want to intervene here we can do
this at home make a Milani looks tired
imagine what are you nuts you get BOTOX
well I just get a little bit right here
you know I can still move my eyebrows
watch watch
so expressing
oh look come on we'll go sneak up on him
can you say it no they can't it feels
too late oh my God oh my God I think I'm
gonna throw it right right now right
here
no I don't think I can I can
if I did say that you took it out of
context are you gonna fight me now
he's been lying to me this whole time I
wasn't lying I was encouraging that's
not true you were lying to be
encouraging you know what as an actor
Mark isn't always great so there are
times when you don't think he's good
what do you send them you're so
fantastic really
Mom you're always expecting the best
from me you're welcome
[Music]
I needed to do something meaningful what
you do is is kind of meaningful to who
no one
this whole world is falling apart and
this is what's consuming you well you're
not helping
I love you
okay well never mind
[Music]
thank you
July
[Music]
oh you stink be sure
what is she
[Music]
let's try that again but with ninja
stars
hey why do we pick a fruit shaped
exactly like my head just stop talking
you're ruining my concentration you're
fine chill he's gonna die
[Music]
yeah did you hear that what was that
well not that we can do you guys want to
grab pizza
again I can't
think those are like little Shreks to me
we've prepared our whole life for this
Hannah
Leo what happened is Donnie bleeding it
was an accident
so you were baby turtles who made
contact with mystery goo why don't we
prefer the term ooze but yeah it's like
more like it's just it rolls off the
tongue better yeah
it's nice
[Music]
honey maybe we should just call it a
night you go ahead I gotta finish these
centerpieces and rearrange the seating
chart
yes
hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like Pilates
we got your gift it's your Something
Borrowed brings you good luck except for
Uncle Greg we ended up decapitated on
that forklift but that's not the knives
fall
someone just left that in the bathroom
[Music]
you forgot to put his shirt all the way
up
is it time for dinner
you look so much better than the rest of
us I think the left boom is slightly
lower than the right food something
doesn't feel right
[Applause]
here's the plan
spray him in the ice it won't work right
so many steps
once
not once did I wonder
if I'd be walking handcuffed Through the
Jungle with a live grenade
oh you got it I got it you got it okay
[Music]
that dress is growing on me I wanted
something less traditional
nobody with my family
[Music]
[Applause]
Carol thank you for the cake knife
I'm Ria Khan I am going to be a stunt
woman
[Music]
my sister Lina is the only person who
believes in me want to help me with a
vid for my channel
he helped me with all my training you
are going to be such a great stumbler
that was Doppler but lately she's been
seeing this guy who I think is a bit of
a smarmy wanker
you know it's a truck oh my God we are
chill out now I'm not being dramatic
but these people are evil
I found something
I
am they are not taking her away without
a fight
I will strike down you or anyone else
who tries to get in my way
how about the bikini area
Let's Dance
we need to get Lena out
how Mischief is a foot
Nina's not going anywhere you little
[__]
mom what are you doing now
[Music]
nothing changes
we are going to show Rina who these
people really are
crazy
[Applause]
did you see my kick of course I bloodied
it it was magical
I'm pretty sure I drew blood
it's a reunion about to crack we got the
whole free back really [__] a cabin in
the woods got listed all that
perspective for all y'all enjoyment you
still slave to the white man I'm gonna
stop calling my wife the white man all
right
[Music]
what kind of house is this
the blackening
[Applause]
this [__] probably runs on racism
refused to play and she dies
I think we have to play the game in your
predicament the black character is
always the first to die I will spare
your lives if you sacrificed the person
you deemed the blackest to blackest
nobody should judge anybody in here bro
you have two minutes to decide
don't can't pick me I'm gay oh Clifton
yeah that can prove him not the blackest
prove it I've never seen Friday
voted for Trump what
twice
up we need a plan don't say don't you
dare don't say this don't see you we
have to split up
your time has run out it's time to die
[Music]
there's a crazy person oh yeah
Rosa Parks on your shirt right we should
be sitting down right now I mean
that's exactly what she did
made you look
black women gotta save every one of us
yo stop playing
I got a gun
that's too DMX what are you doing
I have terrible news your grandfather is
dead I don't even know him they want me
to fly to Rome tomorrow night to settle
his Affairs I mean shouldn't I stay here
and work on my marriage Kristen start
thinking about you
I landed safe in Italy the Colosseum all
right
time to go to the funeral
[Music]
is going on
my dying wish is that you feed a new
boss the valbara family
I've got a lot going on at home my son
just went to college and my husband just
cheated on me you know what we should
take care of it no
no
no no no no
we need someone whose level
I'm assuming and empathetic did you just
call me pathetic
we are in the middle of a war with our
enemies
we have to kill those Romanos before
they kill us
okay look it's really hard to find three
and a half hours
how are we supposed to appear strong
when she is this you look like a
librarian
finally hot Italian men yet
he tried to kill me
you're the boss the boss takes care of
business I made muffins
I'm a little tired of this war my family
is tired of this war
oh TripAdvisor does not lie can I
hi I'm still in the dark here
I don't know it's a figure of speech
[Music]
I am so
passed down to you but
I wanted a child the greatest gift of my
life
[Music]
I'm visiting my mother tomorrow
hi Karen it's Mom I'm just calling to
say that I'm so so excited to see
you're my angel and I love you
okay I love you okay bye sweetie I love
you
are you at the airport I'm on my way I
just
it's not safe is it
what do you think I should do
I'm sure you'll do the right thing
sweetheart
welcome back I hit you with my car
what I know
what was this that's my little assistant
health monitor
sad about going
[Music]
to be leaving I don't know if that's
gonna happen
[Music]
you will walk many miles
dozens will become hundreds
[Music]
will become thousands
your adventures will continue for years
and years this is a good home I know
[Music]
explosion it's not for me
do you want the truth now
[Music]
I'm gonna have to meet you in there I've
only just finished my last valuation
[Music]
the office clown award goes to rain red
Delaney
[Music]
because I quit
you've got fired and quick but in the
same day well that's new what are you
going to do
how long have you been performing Dolly
no tonight was just an unfortunate
mistake
we're casting for a new Dolly at the
moment let's see what you're made of
she's brat she's bubbly nipples to the
sky green brass oh wow makeup's a little
extra
thank you very much you strike me as
someone who doesn't stick to things this
is where I belong this is what I'm
supposed to be doing baby I'm burning
out of control yeah you're weird enough
I'll give you that so I'm gonna throw
you a Boat Show Me What You're Made Of
time
those who know how to have a good time
and those who are willing to learn
you're off on some wild sequined goose
chase that isn't gonna end well fine I'm
fighting too constantly what I said
starting oh God mum I'm not an idiot and
it will end well if it kills me Dolly
all dead
what happened it's fine it's not fun you
look crazy but just get it together okay
[Music]
thank you very much has he left the
building yet
game's about to start oh this time oh
what a beautiful I like Gronkowski we
know Chris we've all read your grand
erotica it's not erotica it's fan
fiction very sexy fan fiction
aren't you tired of the same old boring
lives let's go to the Super Bowl the
Super Bowl is no place for four old
women this could be Tom's last one he's
almost 40. that's like 80 in people
years yeah we're 80 in people years I
just really need this trip
[Music]
I can't believe we're actually here
taking this one he's cute so you don't
have any tickets how much for four ten
thousand ten thousand well I have a 20
in my strap-on that's a fanny pack if
you work like this it's a strap-on wow
foreign
[Music]
no no
no
[Applause]
let's go oh my God that's time
these are good very good oh careful
they're high dosage high dosage
excuse me I'm looking for someone
are you okay
I'm an idiot
it's showtime I don't deserve these
Powers if I'm being honest like what am
I even contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
Aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and Batman it's so cool and I'm
just me
[Music]
I feel like a fraud it doesn't matter
um anyway a wizard gave me super powers
well then everybody got super powers but
is everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right
come on
the fate of the world depends on it
coming for you
[Music]
children stored the power of all the
gods
very
[Music]
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies Lady it's all about
family
family guys that was a signal
[Music]
the world will not survive this
we fight powers like this
I think I know how to fix this dude but
I really don't
everyone can be worthy let's give it a
chance
y'all go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
day
business
a devoted wife and mother a doting
grandmother Joyce was a wonderful woman
this is Claire one of Joyce's oldest
friends they were College together
[Applause]
word
kill you
now that she's gone we're gonna do it
this weekend
Evelyn I need to talk to you about what
I told him I was going to kill him
I could chat it's been four and a half
decades feels like it was yesterday you
were delusional she told me you were
cruel
so what's the plan Scarface I'm gonna
buy a gun it was cute very want to hold
it and I'm gonna take it to the wake
how's the recoil
I'm not gonna lie it has a little kick
well darn it we tried do you have any
poison I have a cyanide pill in case I'm
captured by the enemy you can have it
[Applause]
I want you to tell the truth I I am
shocked by your utter selfishness blame
me for what happened in your own
marriage I think you were not built for
happiness I mean you're in what my other
murder cancer this week so I've got time
I've missed you you've had my number
well you had my number so we're both
lousy friends
[Music]
oh
why are you carrying that knife oh I was
gonna stab someone
crab cakes
who is it
Ralph I slept by them
I don't want to get Knocked Up
foreign
[Music]
hey everyone this is my cousin's sister
Sam she's from L.A staying with me now
nice to meet you I'm Melissa captain of
the price team let's take it from the
top Break Every Chain Break Every Chain
this song needs to life up in here Sam
can help she writes songs the chorus is
the strongest product if we lose the
rest and type the Loose Ends it could be
really special lose the rest
every team has their Lane and our lane
is real church music how about you learn
an actual gospel song first
time's the only thing Atlanta has gone
for it okay about to go up and they're
about to meet him it's about to be great
I would like to thank my cousin Jess for
being my rider dog in Atlanta when my
dad forced me to go out there and I
didn't want to go out there that's
family business we outside oh God
your voice is nice why don't you come
down to the studio
you should say that song at that church
thing
[Music]
I changed the music what it's gonna be
great we are terrified I don't really
have a relationship with God God use
fish donkeys even hoes to get his word
across what's going on I think she just
called me hug
oh I like this twerking for the Lord we
do not think you're going straight to
hell as some people have said oh Church
Girl Gotta put him out there
[Applause]
so y'all really think God's gonna waste
a miracle on y'all this year huh shall I
heard that clap back all the way over
here let's get our praise on
three songs hit people's heart a little
different hands on hands up
[Applause]
[Music]
can I get an amen amen
seven years ago one incredible story
blew up the internet when I was 22 I got
involved with the Russian mafia I was a
frat boy at a class trip this is Igor
here for your protection he's very
dangerous to talk to or hang out with
him all I want to do is hang out with
him I did not speak Russian
all I knew how to say was
[Applause]
it was literally the best summer of my
life we robbing this guy
three years after those events
the story continues what is wrong with
this shirt
yeah machine not today brother not today
my dad showed up you paid money to see
my son tell his made-up story about
robbing a train for the million times
it's a true story it took about two
seconds before he started making me
mental look at it
he's a monster
are you the machine man the party's
outside 23 years ago he was told the
only thing my father never cared about
sorry is this some sort of tick tock
prank I'm about to lose my [__] it's
definitely a prank clearly that's a fake
gun
or not they're coming with me back to
Russia Russia
he's going down
what's up why are you talking about fast
like you're on speed or something if I'm
on speed oh more drugs
[Applause]
take off that shirt and show those sobs
who you really are now you gotta party
with me
he's the machine
[Music]
fine I'm just gonna shoot him in the leg
oh my God I'm going to freaking hell I
killed a man well
suddenly you killed several men
medieval France a time that ushered in a
new era of nobility not another God
killed that one yes I am
I'm sorry who killed him I couldn't my
Lord I have known or no my entire life
we came up together as Squires would it
be easier if we got a third guard to
come in and kill both of these guys oh
whoops here we go
oh
good work hey
buddy buddy
holy [__] come on we're gonna be late
you know what your problem is is it that
I've got a fatty deposit the size of a
giant gourd on my back
punch back morning
[Music]
the Royal torture chamber back to the
Daily Grind you guys psych for pump week
oh my God here we go I love both weeks
to see an extra
[Applause]
lottery winner of the lottery shall have
his private confession heard by the pope
himself what he won a hunchback no do
you have any idea the questions he'll
have for me Holy Father can you fix my
home is not my very existence proof
there is no God I don't want to get into
that whole Hornet's Nest
you're gonna ask for a new bag oh yeah
like a tall bag baby or perhaps a new
face no man would like that face they'd
be like put it back in my vagina okay on
4 20.
[Music]
tale of love I very much like your rack
and I yours
betrayal
and Scandal well these are actual
depictions of the Pope having sex with
saracen women oh Mount Your is that mud
it's not mud
it's not mine everyone plays a part
or chew
send a warning shot shoot over the heads
yes Lord
Michelle
whoops I said shoot over the heads I'm
not even sure that that was my arrow I
saw it come out of your crossbow you
know what that was Gregor's Gregor
[Music]
foreign